contributor to the 911 Commission report
he takes a critical look at the history
of American counterterrorism in his new
book blind spot this top from the
International Spy Museum in Washington
DC is one hour come to the International
Spy Museum I'm Peter earnest the
executive director we are absolutely
delighted to have such a great turnout
today one of the things we've been
considering lately is getting the word
out to people who might be interested in
things like this and one of the things
we were doing for some time was email
bless I'm just interested what brought
you all here obviously some of you know
other people and I know and I know some
of you I don't all of you by the way I
should mention to you that you are all
on c-span so for those of you who are
concerned about cover issues I urge you
to pull out your scarf and glasses as
people in this town er want to do and we
will have about a 30-minute presentation
by dr. Naftali and after which be wide
open for a QA and then make his way back
to the table there for signing the books
for any of those who are interested this
is truly am I not on I wasn't before all
those jokes are wasted good afternoon
welcome to the International Spy Museum
I'm Peter earnest the executive director
I'll cut out all the stuff in the middle
I think what makes this book
particularly valuable for us I think
there are a couple of things that struck
me and going through it I had known Tim
Naftali dr. Neftali several years ago
when he was working on a an espionage
case from a historical point of view and
that has been his specialty and we were
covering the case of the first double
agent in Europe and was truly a sort of
a nostalgia trip of nostalgia if you
like but was such a pleasure meeting
here and I was so impressed by his
knowledge of counterespionage and
counterintelligence and I think the
thing that is always a surprise to those
of us who've been practitioners I was as
I know a number of you know I was in CIA
I was in the clandestine service for
some 20 some years but we are so
compartmentalized when we are in the
field or when we are at work that it is
so hard for us to get the broader view
to get the bird's eye view to see how
things really work in terms of policy
and I think what makes this book so
valuable is first of all it is about how
counterterrorism evolved in this country
in our time but more than that it makes
it come alive this is not a dry recital
of n SDS and and skids and what
legislation was passed these are the
players this is President Clinton this
is President Bush this is Richard Clark
this is Condoleezza Rice and these are
people down in the weeds my colleagues
and the CIA other colleagues in the FBI
these are their names what they did and
why they did what they did I think we so
often all of us whether we're
practitioners are we we come even from
interested lay circles we see reports in
the media but they're fragmentary we go
on and read other things this book is a
seamless history this takes you from
when we first started being concerned
about terrorism when we lost our concern
about terrorism well we were rican
cerned about terrorism and it takes you
through that very uneven pace and why it
was because so often it's easy for us to
think it's mindless they don't know what
they're doing in the government it's
just mindless and you'll find that it
may not be mindless there may be reasons
you may not agree with the reasons but
he brings them out I had I had just two
quotes if I can use the privilege of
introducing Tim he says here at one
point in his introduction after years of
studying the intelligence and security
world I have come to believe less in the
efficiency of conspiracies than I do in
the inefficiency of government and one
other one I would touch on historically
what we refer to as intelligence
failures are policy failures and what
this does it tries to get us away from
pointing from the policy people pointing
their finger at the intelligence house
and the intelligence house pointing its
finger back at the policy people he he
weaves them together and makes it make
sense and that was what was so valuable
about your book for me tim as i'm sure
some of you know tim was asked by the
911 Commission specifically by ernest
may from harvard and Phil's elico who
was the executive director to prepare a
history for the commission of the
background of terrorism something that
they could identify with and take it
right up through 911 that is precisely
what he did so what you are seeing here
to a large extent formed much of the
basis of what the 911 Commission had in
its mind as a memory of how we got to
911 the ups and downs and the successes
and failures the intense interest and
the loss of interest just a couple of
other things and let's go Wanda Tim Tim
is currently an associate professor at
the presidential recordings program at
the University of Virginia
the excuse me Miller center of Public
Affairs he teaches cold war and
intelligence history he was a consultant
as I mentioned previously the 911
Commission he also is a consultant to
the Nazi war crimes and imperial
japanese government records interagency
working group and he's currently writing
a history of counterespionage now
there's one thing in this introduction
that I have never seen before so i will
mention it now because no one has ever
put it in their biography it says that
tim is also a blogger for the Huffington
Post make of that what you will so
blogger historian and certainly a
wonderful insight into this country's
history of counterterrorism please help
me welcome Timothy Neftali new cycles
have changed now they're just because we
get news more often doesn't mean it's
any better but i do believe blogging has
allowed for a democracy of ideas that
when my first book came out in 1997 just
didn't exist we live in very jittery
times but i'd like to take you back to a
time that was much less jittery I'm
going to kill you I am a sick man the
young man saying these words pointed a
shiny silver plated 45 automatic at the
white-haired gentleman he passed on the
way to the front of the plane the old
man was Senator James OS lunaire Minh of
the Senate Judiciary Committee who had
left his seat to go to the lavatory when
this man rushed by him with a gun
eastland ran back to his seat but wasn't
that concerned he wasn't even concerned
when it became clear that the plane he
was sitting on had been hijacked to Cuba
because in the summer of nineteen sixty
eight Americans flying to destinations
in the American South knew there was a
real possibility that their plane would
be
jacked and diverted to Cuba this Delta
Airlines flight scheduled to fly from
Baltimore to Houston was the eighth
commercial jetliner hijacked in the
United States that year alone since
nineteen sixty one the year the first US
commercial plane was hijacked 21 planes
had been commandeered in flight and all
but one had gone to Havana hijackings to
Havana were so frequent that pilots
flying in the southern United States
routinely took maps of Jose Marti
Airport the Havana airport with them in
the cockpit hijackings to Cuba were so
common that the Cuban government had set
up a lunch system so that when these
unexpected visitors to the sunny island
who were probably peak ish a peckish
arrived they would have a Cuban sandwich
to enjoy while waiting to go home the
Cubans never lacks in finding ways to
gain hard currency also managed to set
up an arrangement through the Swiss
government to get the State Department
to pay $35 a sandwich the Swiss
government which then is now represented
our interests with the Cubans the Swiss
government produced a form with a blank
for the flight number and a blank for
the date so that they could just fill in
those blanks whenever an American plane
passenger and crew found its way to
Havana those were very different times
imagine in that era a senator a cranky
rather powerful senator find himself on
a hijacked plane and there would be no
legislative consequences whatsoever no
congressional inquiry no presidential
statement it was all very routine in
fact when the senator Eastland was asked
after the flight whether he thought
perhaps the gut the country should pass
a series of laws that might might create
a bit of security at American airports
his response was grumble grumble grumble
these hijackers are a product of this
permissive society I blame the Warren
Court we don't need new laws laws are
just like those gun laws
unnecessary well if you were to fly in
1968 you would have noticed no security
whatsoever at an airport your bags
weren't checked you weren't checked
indeed as I would discover not until
1973 that the United States government
Institute 100% screening of passengers
and carry on luggage in piecing together
the story of how we went from a period
of lacks attitude towards if you will
armed disturbances to the jittery moment
that we live in today i noticed a period
of complacency cycle of complacency
mobilization and demobilization and as
Peter mentioned this is a cycle that's a
sine wave really it's not as if you have
one slope that brings you from 1968 and
a lack of care to September 11 what you
have over a course of 30 plus years is
periods of mobilization towards a
terrorist threat terrorist threat
defined differently over time of course
then demobilization then complacency
then you start again to explain why I
became interested in this I'd like to
tell you a little bit about why I'm a
historian and I'm a historian for two
reasons vampires and hot water bottles
vampires because my my family comes from
Transylvania and unless you have a sense
of diplomatic history you cannot
understand why one's grandparents come
from a Hungarian speaking part of
Romania speak Hungarian and Romania and
dislike Hungarians and Romanians that's
one reason I just basically had to
understand the treaty of trianon to
figure out who I was but the hot water
bottle get to something that Peter
mentioned I don't know if you've ever
needed a hot water bottle until I
visited an area just north of Liverpool
I had never really needed one my
grandmother used one but I thought it
was rather quaint and I grew up in
Canada where we do have central heating
but one would need it in Canada in
England in the manor home that I visited
central heating was not possible or at
least didn't exist and I had the good
fortune to invited to be invited to
spend the evening at the home of roger
fleetwood hesketh he lived in a
wonderful manner on the in merseyside a
home that was filled with beautiful
paintings unfortunately when I visited
there weren't painting so much as there
were just impressions on the wall with
little note cards mentioning the fact
that the paintings have been borrowed by
the National Gallery because the
National Gallery was hosting a beautiful
exhibition at that point of landscape
art from English manor homes why I was
there was a search that I undertook in
the 1980s when I just finished college a
search really for for additional
grandparents I was interested in piecing
together the world of World War two
espionage and counterespionage and Roger
fleek would heffas was a failed
architect but a brilliant deception
planet he was the man he was the brain
he was the ID set of ideas behind the
d-day deception perhaps the most
successful deception in world history
without a doubt the most successful
military deception in the 20th century
and hesketh had written his
recollections of putting together that
marvelous deception and the Thatcher
government had decided not to release it
fortunately mr. hesketh had kept a copy
and he allowed me to read it but I had
to read it at night and it gets very
cold at night in merseyside but thanks
to a hot water bottle I was able to get
through both of the report and the night
successfully when I asked this man why
it was or how it was that he came to
design the trick that it played with
Hitler's mind and it made it possible
for us to land in Normandy without the
bulk of Hitler's Panzer divisions coming
at the second front in destroying it he
said well you know when I was growing up
my sister and I didn't have a lot of
playmates around this is a rather
isolated manor home as many are
so we invented relatives and friends we
had a complete fantasy world that we
created it was if you will a sandbox
conspiracy I met many remarkable
amateurs from that era who together
worked on some of the most successful
counter espionage and espionage
operations in history and this is was in
my mind in those terrible days after 911
when a lot of us were wondering whether
we were up to snuff whether our security
and intelligence services were going to
be able to provide us with the
protection of this apparently new era
required and it was three or four days
after September 11th that the news media
started to pick up the story of Zacarias
Moussaoui who is a since admitted his
crimes and this was a man to remind you
who had come to this country with thirty
one thousand dollars in banker who came
to learn how to fly a plane even though
he had no background in aviation who was
apparently speaking a lot of jihadist
notions and he attracted finally the
attention of some FBI officers in Eagan
Minnesota who both I think the FBI
officers whose attention he attracted
were both pilots and the head friends at
the local air school his hard drive of
his computer could not be looked at
before September 11 for legalistic and I
think cultural reasons and as I read
about this I began to wonder what had
happened since World War two because at
the end of World War two these
characters these wonderful personalities
that I had met had set up and worldwide
system to track bad people and indeed in
1945 they had used the word terrorism to
describe the kinds of activities that
they expected the SS Hitler's security
service to undertake even after Hitler's
death the assumption was the central the
core of German the German state would
collapse but these highly ideologically
motivated people would can
he knew the fight throughout the world
to encourage people to choose fascism
overcome communism and this
international monitoring organization
included members from the British
government the American government and
the French government as well as some of
the Commonwealth governments and it was
a highly centralized organization with
an analytical unit headed by someone
named hugh trevor-roper lake known later
known as lord dacre it was a marvelous
example of what later American
commissions as I would learn called a
fusion center of intelligence
information plus they had they had
operational arms into the field so that
when your counterintelligence Corps
people your people in the field who were
collecting suspects and interrogating
them they actually could get access to
top level information so those
interrogations were useful and then when
it appeared that a suspect was of
particular importance London or
Washington would send a very specialized
person with signals intelligence
information down to the field to make
sure that the most was gleaned from the
suspect it was a remarkable operation
well in 2001 I wondered what had
happened had the DNA been switched out
of US intelligence so that only the
stupid people were left after World War
two where were all these smart people
what happened to the structure that
people got right in 1945 oh of course
it's a simplistic question but it
started me on a on a quest to try to
explain how we got from there to here
and a couple of years later thanks to
earnest painful zelika the Commission in
a sense asked me to to do an even
grander study and allowed me to
interview folks who had been involved in
this very difficult problem of
counterterrorism from nineteen sixty
eight to nineteen ninety-three and then
I decided to expand my study to tell the
story from 45 to 2001 now I want to give
you a sense of the sort of general
conclusions with some specific examples
and then I'll open it to questions and
we can talk about the periods that most
interest you I mean I want you to keep
in mind that the terrorist threat
changes I I don't believe in this
concept of
war on terrorism because you can't
declare war on a tactic terrorism is a
tactic it's used by weak enemies we have
had a series of weak enemies just don't
have tanks to fight us the old-fashioned
way we've had a series of weak enemies
and their faces and ideologies change
over time but the US government has had
to deal with the tactic so when my story
begins so well the SS turned out not to
be structured to carry on this fight
they gave up they gave up largely
because of Eisenhower's brilliant
decision on I have to admit I'm a great
fan of Dwight Eisenhower he in many ways
was this one of the smartest military
minds and one of the greatest presidents
we've had Eisenhower understood the the
only way to defeat a nation is just use
a preponderance of force and so rather
than go and take Berlin with one sale at
one little attack he decided to impress
upon the Germans that they had been
defeated and that crushed the terrorism
problem it disappeared within a few
months but the my story from 68 to the
present is of a series of different
Middle Eastern groups beginning with the
PLO moving to the ante PLO the the the
groups that split off the PLO when yasir
arafat decided to participate in the
diplomatic process the Middle East to
the Shiite groups supported by Iran most
importantly Hezbollah to the new
terrorism of the 1990s the Sunni
extremists personified by Osama bin
Laden but as we know it extends far
beyond him what I learned in looking at
our efforts to deal with a series of
different terrorist threats is that we
don't like to do counterterrorism as a
people as a nation as a government we
can be good at it and my story is not
just a litany of failures we can talk
about a really glorious period of
counterterrorism the late 80s and early
90s one when we got three of our four
greatest terrorist targets but we don't
like to do it and in all layers of our
government we
we don't like to do it presidents are
constantly being told this of course is
before nine eleven we can talk about the
world after nine eleven we live later
before nine eleven presidents were told
by their national security advisers not
to worry about terrorism there were some
exceptions sandy Berger as important
exception Admiral Poindexter is
important exception but by and large if
you look at national security advisors
they were saying two presidents don't
exaggerate the Terrorism problem it's
not a strategic threat to the country
like the Soviet Union or China don't get
wrapped up in fact many signal security
visors like Henry Kissinger would argue
if you overreact to terrorism you're
going to complicate our efforts to
negotiate some kind of settlement in the
Middle East because by and large the
people who are perpetrating terrorism
were people we wanted to talk to people
we were being told by the Egyptian and
Saudi the moderate governments that we
had to talk to the Palestinian
Liberation Organization it might come as
a surprise to you but American diplomats
and civilians were killed overseas
without any US military response until
nineteen eighty-six it was US policy not
to respond we had a public policy of
defiance but privately and in terms of
what we did we never responded not until
we attacked Libya in 1986 the reason for
that is the Pentagon hated the
counterterrorism mission and was an
obstructionist institution time and
again this is sadly ironic because until
nine eleven the US military had suffered
more deaths from terrorism than any
other institution of the I States
government because of Hezbollah
successful bombing of the Marine
barracks in beirut in 1983 nevertheless
time and again secretaries of defense
found reasons not to use force they were
focused on the Soviet target they felt
terrorism was a misuse of resources they
feared losing very expensively trained
pilots in a
acts on what they call jungle gyms my
favorite example of the Pentagon's
unwillingness to undertake
counterterrorism is this story from the
mid-1990s the United States began the
now notorious a policy of rendition
which is basically at initially designed
to bring people back to this country
who'd been indicted in American court so
that they could be tried very noble
actually a very noble and important
objective the the CIA generally used its
airplanes to bring these people back but
the CIA at least then did not have the
capability of refueling its planes in
the air only the US Air Force can do
that and there are a number of
renditions that the United States
government wanted to complete very
quickly without having to stop in a
friendly country on the way over always
in created paperwork to stop in Britain
or to stop in Cairo depending on where
you picked up this malefactor and the
FBI and the CIA cuz they always work
they work together on these things went
to the Air Force in the mid-1990s and
said would you please bring this person
back the Air Force didn't want to do it
so they were pressed and finally the Air
Force said fine we'll do it so they
brought this person back and then they
handed the FBI a bill for 12 million
dollars 12 million dollars that is a
very expensive flight let me tell you
well this was a just this was a slap in
the face the FBI and the Clint
administration decided to do something
about it and so in the summer of
nineteen ninety-five Bill Clinton signed
an executive order so that one part of
the US government could not obstruct the
rendition by another part of us go and
this was directed to the Pentagon and
the result of that is the Pentagon could
no longer charge the FBI for using its
planes to bring back someone on a
national security mission but that gives
you a sense of the institutional
obstacles even into the 1990s that
prevented an efficient American approach
to counterterrorism Congress didn't like
counterterrorism
the reason Congress didn't like
counterterrorism is it well let's let's
parse this a bit better I talked about
both counterterrorism and anti-terrorism
counterterrorism are those efforts we
take abroad to undermine destroy
neutralize terrorist organizations
generally the CIA does this but when we
use the military the Pentagon is doing
it anti-terrorism consists of those
measures that we input in place to
defend ourselves at home and to make it
harder for the enemy to plan an attack
that would be involved of course those
those long lines at airports the port
security systems that we're setting up
now that's anti-terrorism now
anti-terrorism measures do involve
limits to personal liberty and do
introduce inefficiencies in commerce
when the threat level appears to be low
understandably Congress the American
people American business they're not
interested in these limitations on
freedom and free trade throughout the
period that I studied the case was never
made to Congress effectively that there
should be some limits on personal
liberty and freedom and freedom of
Commerce it had to be as a result of an
event attack time and again we would
have to be hit before Congress would was
willing and the federal government was
willing to impose certain limitations
draconian limitations I'm talking about
one hundred percent screening of
passengers at airports for example you
know in the first three months of 1973
after the US government implemented this
screening process do you know how many
guns were picked up at US airports 5,000
5,000 people in three months were
intending to board planes with firearms
and this wasn't wasn't just happening in
Texas and this wasn't these weren't
5,000 putative or hijackers but it was a
different era the FAA which is a lobby
at least then was a lobby for the US
airline industry consistently opposed
security measures at airports because
they were unnecessary in fact they told
Congress in under testimony what you
want us to do check every passenger
there was no desire in the part of
Congress and this continues into the
1990s what may strike you as as
surprising but it is true a number of
the provisions in the patriot act of
2001 were first introduced by the
Clinton administration in the mid-1990s
as a way of tightening our domestic
security to terrorism these were posed
by a strong coalition an odd coalition
of House Republicans and the far left
House Republicans argued that the
greatest threat to Americans is the
federal government and therefore refused
to give the FBI the kinds of powers that
today House Republicans say the FBI
needed all along I'm non-partisan in my
text there are Democrats that get a lot
of grief but in this case it's a
Republican story because it just shows
you how politics change in the 1990s
this government it then Clinton
administration tried to undertake some
prudent measures to tighten our domestic
security and they were blocked by
Congress this was a period of Ruby Ridge
you might remember it this is a period
of of there was great tension in the
country of a lot of sort of militant
pro-white groups were talking up in the
Far West this is a very poisonous period
in American history and the result was
though a measure was passed in nineteen
ninety-six it was a pale reflection pale
imitation of what the clinton
ministration tried to pass in 1995
between the Clinton and President Bush
administration's the only sort of the
only link the only group of people who
had access to intelligence on bin Laden
was Congress yes in
is given in the transition to the new
leadership but there's always going to
be a from a slight fumble of the ball
from one to another it's it's part of
its one of the sort of weaknesses in our
system because of the four-year cycle
Congress however gets access to all this
intelligence through its intelligence
committees where was Congress at the end
of two thousand and in 2001 when the
bush administration altered its list of
threats to this country why wasn't
anyone in Congress saying wait a second
the United States was went to war
against bin Laden after the East African
bombings of 1998 where was Congress
Congress never takes responsibility but
it was the only branch of government
that was in continuous control of the
intelligence information on bin Laden
during that very difficult period
between during the long election of two
thousand and the transition to the Bush
administration of 2001 and I'm afraid
the American public also doesn't like
counterterrorism for perfectly good
under reasons I'm a civil libertarian
too I don't want unnecessary
restrictions on my Liberty but I need
leaders to help explain to me the nature
of the threat and because presidents
have been consistently told by their
national security advisers not to take
personal responsibility for terrorism
again up to 911 with a few exceptions
the public never understood the nature
of the threat from terrorism why would
national security staffs make this
argument very simple it was viewed the
terrorism was inevitable but it was low
level it was a chronic skin disease it
wasn't going to kill you but it wasn't
going to go away political staffs don't
like presidents to be associated with
problems that can't be solved and so
with the exceptions of Bill Clinton and
Ronald Reagan presidents have not
identified themselves with fighting
terrorism it's an odd couple but in fact
they were the two most successful
presidents are dealing with the problem
of terrorism one last point we did this
well and we did it well in the late 80s
and early 90s because of a nimble group
of CIA officers who tracked down and
neutralized
I burned the Abu Nidal organization
Carlos the Jackal who was a terrorist
entrepreneur who worked primarily for
the PLO and finally Adam I'll Guzman the
head of the shining path in Peru who's
associated with at least the deaths of
60,000 people it was good
counterterrorism good intelligence
gathering smart liaison work that led to
those three successes now the fourth was
Hezbollah and the Reagan administration
tried to deal with Hezbollah by buying
off its patron Iran and that was the
Iran side of Iran Contra and that did
not work very well but we can be good at
this and since nine eleven we've tried
to be better but I would argue and we'll
discuss this in the QA that there are
pathologies in the way in which we deal
with counterterrorism that haven't
completely got away despite the fact
that no one now argues the terrorism is
anything less but a major threat to the
country there are institutional reasons
and political reasons why we're not as
effective and efficient at this game as
we should be given the current threat
thanks very much
yes yes 10 I want to take a few you
mentioned in your remarks which is the
question of why things change so much
between nineteen forty-five or 1946 with
war ended and the case of saccharides
was Sally and I want to I want to get
your comment as I have a theory and I
don't know if you've had a chance to
read Bob Woodward's latest book and who
kinda zation well he one of the things
that he described is something that it's
been going around it he had viously
answers a question that has been that
has arisen since the outing of mark felt
as deep throat that is why if Mark felt
was motivated by disgusted at his
beloved FBI being turned for political
purposes by the Nixon administration how
does that explain how he himself was
indicted for the black-bag operations
and one word answers that question
because he talks to felt and around this
era and the answer is that felt was
motivated by a desire to thwart
political violence and it was the
weather underground and the fugitives
that were Weather Underground characters
that he and he and the bureau brass
thought were the great the greatest
natural security threat they faced and
he thought that he was properly
motivated
because he was a counterterrorism
professional and the question that I
guess the observation that I have is is
if that's the case is it not the our
tendency to indict people like that when
they go a little bit too far that might
be the problem that that explains why
there's such difference between 1945 and
2001 it's a great question bear with me
I thought a lot about this this is about
how our society differentiates between
descent and extremism at the end of
World War two the British I go back to
the British because they taught us a lot
about how to deal with how to do
intelligence we got very good at it very
fast but but they were our mentors and
to some extent they've been our mentors
on the counter terrorism side but
perhaps not as much as it should have
been the case they taught us something
they don't have a bill of rights they
don't have a constitution after all that
makes sense our Constitution is a
reaction to the the nature and evolution
of British government and what we did
was enumerate protections that were not
properly protected in the British system
so it makes sense that we have in a
sense a series of enumerated right
switch which are much stronger in
practice than what the British have and
the parliamentary system majority
government can move and change laws very
fast we're seeing that now in Britain
it's much harder when you have divided
government of the Republican style
government the British taught us how to
spy on citizens the British you see
because they lack the constitutional
guarantees that we have the british home
secretary could put a warrant on anyone
very easily is very easy and insect fact
is the british had a system of basically
reading every letter every private
letter every private telegram the
british collected information on
everybody who flew on international
planes now that was a lot easier in 1945
or 44 then it then it would be now of
course but but let me tell you
the British structure the thinking of
behind the British system was one that
is alien to us because as anyone who's a
lawyer or has to work about worry about
these things there are a series of
protections that make that kind of
blanket surveillance impossible for a US
government in peacetime if it's acting
constitutionally what happened after
World War two is that the US government
tried to continue this blanket
surveillance policy illegally
unconstitutionally because it had been
so successful in World War two in the
book I call it the channels theory
because what and where we we have to
rehab to recreate it but my argument in
the book is got to recreate it with the
public being behind you you have to be
honest about it and open the US
government's from Roosevelt through
Nixon did this secretly a series of
postmaster generals knew that we were
engaged in unconstitutional activity of
general of opening American male it was
illegal we did it because we knew where
we thought it was an effective way of
acquiring information that's how the US
government acquired information about
Lee Harvey Oswald's letters to his mom
and letters back to Russia we didn't get
a lot of very good information but that
was a little bit that came out of this
system so what happens in the mid-1970s
is that seymour hersh and others find
out that we have this sort of not ice a
blanket it wasn't that effective but it
was an effort to acquire information on
everything travel Telegraph which was
important that letters and the public
because this is a very hard time in
American history there's the Arab of
Watergate Watergate has already under
investigation as a period of Vietnam
we're losing this war the American
public is concerned it's always
concerned about executive power but now
you have if you will a coalition of the
right and the left that are concerned
about executive power and this
information results in a mad and
understandable but very dramatic
counter-reaction against the FBI and the
CIA now the FBI had been
undertaking some very very questionable
and illegal actions against civil rights
workers in the 60s uh they had they had
exceeded their was there their powers
with support of edgar Hoover in dealing
with the weather on ground and other
domestic political dissenters and
terrorists The Weather Underground did
kill some people and the reaction to
this was to say we're not going to try
to differentiate between dissent and
extremism we're not going to do any
political intelligence at all that was
how the US government handled this we're
just going to step back and not do it at
all unless there's a criminal predicate
or unless there is evidence of a foreign
intelligence service that is using this
person apparently the laws actually were
not as we're not as restrictive with
regard to foreign terrorism
organizations but the FBI convinced
itself that it couldn't do any political
intelligence and was only it was only if
the higher powers the FBI director and
others pushed them that they would do it
and they rarely got that kind of push so
there is certainly in a institutional
and cultural a product of the 1970s that
made doing counterterrorism at home much
harder the CIA handled this differently
the CIA was never that comfortable with
foreign assassinations if you look at
the record of the 1960s yes there were
some people in the agency like Richard
Bissell and others who were were keen on
on getting rid of Castro getting rid of
patrice lumumba but but the whole the
agency itself had a lot of grumblers
about this those who knew about it so
the agency was absolutely happy to wash
its hands of foreign assassinations and
in the 1980s when it became clear that
lebanon was a problem hezbollah was a
problem that and that people might have
to be killed in the hezbollah
organization you could see the CIA at
least as i as i did the the history the
CIA saying what we don't want to do this
again we got into trouble for this this
is we don't want to do it again and
there you do see the legacy of the 60s
and early 70s it took a long time to get
over of the counter reaction
action of the 1970s and no doubt played
a role in our inefficiencies on
September ten 2000 01 yes a couple of
things have a quick question with regard
to the trevor-roper organization I
wonder if you might give us some details
as to its nature and activity and how it
disappeared and the second one is a
little broader and sense of the ability
of people who find themselves in careers
in places like the Pentagon and the FBI
being able to effectively deal with the
subtleties I would say for example I
think there was a big mistake in the
overthrow of Mossadegh for example and
the consequences of that sort of
thinking that this was the big threat
and so therefore we should take action
so I wonder if you might deal with the
ability of government agencies staffed
as they are to actually deal effectively
with clinical affairs his way that's a
huge the second one is a huge question
and I have a very sort of I don't
pretend to have the policy solutions for
things but I notice patterns in the past
we're generally well served when the
people who helped shape policy know
something of the culture and language of
the groups that they're studying I think
it's almost should be a requirement that
there is no it is obvious but it's not
the way it works you know the people who
are writing estimates on the Soviet
Union in the CIA didn't know Russian in
the 50s because the assumption was it
was a political science assumption that
you don't need to know any cultures
because all nation-states act the same
so this may seem obvious but in fact
it's not the way the US government works
and the second point is in the US
government we we knew US government
people who stay in the same job and get
to know a certain patch really well our
viewed as failures they don't get
promoted because the people get promoted
of the people who who become deputy of
this region and largely the CIA but also
the FBI deputy of this region then chief
of that region or part of the country
we don't really we don't really reward
people who get to know a patch really
well and that's a mistake hugh
trevor-roper it's a great story we can
talk about this offline but the last
days of Adolf Hitler was a book that he
wrote it's wonderful it's an
intelligence study that he wrote for mi5
the British then the Imperial security
now just the security service and it's
it's an intelligent study of the death
of Hitler to prove that he had died and
that he was not living in in South
America there were some really really
good analyses of the SS the most
important part of this story they
recognized they were wrong and they
within three months they recognized the
SS had coke disappeared and that this
was no longer a terrorism threat I say
this because institutions rarely like to
recognize that they've made a mistake
and I admire institutions that are smart
enough to say oops the threat is not
what we thought it was and to be public
about it and they did so we should learn
from that because i don't i see
institutions making quick calls about
the nature of a threat whether it's the
London bombing reasoning and not backing
away when it turns out they were wrong
this group headed by a huge ever Oprah
admitted oh we don't have this terrorism
threat thank goodness move on to
something else yes yes jump so then you
disagree with
historians of the world
oh I thought that was discredited um I'm
sorry I'm not gonna do she's a very she
wasn't that she was then the National
Security Advisor wasn't she she's a busy
woman I will say that if you want to see
if you're looking and be careful by the
way of using historical lessons I say
look for patterns but but don't try to
impede don't try to use as a as a guide
to the letter of a policy a case that
happened 40 years ago be careful of
these false parallels however if you're
looking to see one of the advantages of
using overwhelming force to eliminate
insurgencies and to prevent terrorism in
an occupied land look at the debates in
the US government in 1944 and you'll see
if you just change Germany to Iraq
that's what happened and in the case of
the Roosevelt government they chose to
use overwhelming force and they got rid
of the insurgency and I'll leave for you
to complete the sentence yes I have a
couple concerns it seems to me what we
is the public see are things that
inconvenience as jersey barriers and
they tell about the airline searches and
such even in museums
so we don't really know what's happening
in the terrorists fight underground one
of my questions is how important is the
outing of valerie plame what was she
doing or what what are we doing and is
her knowledge of WMDs is there anything
that can be sacrificed their but isn't
there an alternative to military force
when we're talking about Tara
anti-terrorism I don't know how I don't
know what she was doing I see this isn't
it's an important matter and it's a
legal matter I just think that at a time
when we're trying to be fighting
terrorists we shouldn't be disclosing
the identities of the people who are
fighting and helping us fight this
battle yes recently a few weeks back
Melissa Malloy was here she was talking
about the terrorist threat and at the
CIA and she was are the combat to the
CIA i imply the CIA the CIA fight
against terrorism and she was talking
about one of the mistakes they made is a
must they took it as an organization
instead of an ideology has there been a
qualitative shift from what for instance
abu nidal organization and even Shining
Path which seemed to be tied in to it
leader has there been a shift to an
ideology of
I don't know I just know what I've read
and I've read that but again you know
you have to be careful newspapers
reflect leaks and leaks can often be
intentional to drive some kind of
internal policy debate that we know the
parameters of which we don't know I
would be terribly disappointed if I
found out that our view was was was that
simplistic and that we had sort of
shifted from one pretty inflexible sense
of what terrorism is to one to another
pretty inflexible sense of terrorism I'm
not saying you're making that argument
I'm I would be terribly disappointed if
that's the way we've looked at this
because in historically that's not the
way we've looked at it the one
inflexible idea that in a sense created
the blind spot which provided me with a
title was this idea that terrorists will
hit us abroad because it's easier and
they're going to hit American
installations military and civilian
diplomatic abroad it's too hard for them
to operate here and you might you'll see
in the book Vice President George HW
Bush overseas a very interesting
commission that looks at the Terrorism
problem in in 1985 and 86 and then we
looks at again in 87 and they interview
uh William Webster was then at FBI
directory is about to become DCI and
Webster says you know one reason that we
don't won't have this problem here at
least now is that our domestic Muslim
population is happy they've chosen to
come here they live better they get jobs
and thank God so far for obvious reasons
are we don't have a rest of domestic
Muslim American population that i know
of although i'm not an expert in that
field but there was a blind spot about
that was an inflexible idea that that we
weren't going to be attacked and even
Richard Clark and I give him great
credit for jumping up and down and
saying bin Laden bin Laden bin Laden and
getting the attention of the president
even Richard Clark if you look at his
policy advice the advice that he crafted
in late two thousand four this is
actually during the long recount so he
not clear who was for but then that he
repackages and gives to condi rice in
early two thousand one and has finally
given to the president a few months
later that advice was to use the same
tools and the same strategy against bin
Laden that had been used against Abu
Nidal it was a three to five year plan
to through attrition to deal with al
Qaeda now that's not the kind of advice
you're going to give to the president if
we're a few months away from being
attacked at home even he was caught by
this sort of inflexible idea that
they're going to hit us abroad before
they hit us here but I'm assuming and
hoping that that we understand that
jihadism metastasized in the 90s bin
Laden is was the most successful in
terms of numbers of people killed but
he's not the only jihadist there were a
the 911 Commission talks about the case
of Khalid Sheikh Mohammed and ramzi
yousef I talked about roms use if you
look at those cases these were jihadists
who were looking for a mentor a patron
and they went to they went to bin Laden
or in the case of Yusuf he went to
Sheikh Mohammed and and Muhammad went to
22 bin Laden that phenomena of
entrepreneurs jihadist opener
entrepreneurs looking for backing money
cover that's a 90s phenomenon that
hasn't stopped and it won't so getting
al-qaeda is just one part of the the
struggle yes what we always hear about
American colleges very superior terms of
Technology very deficient in terms of
human intelligence
and I just wanted to know if you agree
with that assessment or do you think as
it as you said earlier it's a policy
failure more than a failure human
intelligence we're building okay and
phenomena is a phenomenal museum ok walk
through this building which not which
doesn't just deal with the United States
history of US intelligence but but
Soviet and other intelligence service
and and and count how many great human
spies there were it's really really hard
for any country to penetrate the
leadership circle of the enemy first of
all it's hard to know who your enemy is
and and if you want to penetrate them if
you do know who your enemy is it takes a
while to penetrate them and you better
be lucky you know the the Israelis have
known who their enemies were for a long
time and they have had some very
successful human intelligence agents but
not as many as you would expect during
the Cold War I can name on one hand
until the until the late 80s when when
when the system was collapsing and a lot
of them were fleeing and trying to to
make money in a get a new career I can
name on one hand the really important
human penetrations that we had and we
had 40 years to work the target not six
months or two years or what have you
it's very hard and it is easy to jump up
and down and say human human human when
you look at the book you will notice
that this is what the press and Congress
do over and over again nineteen ninety
ninety eight the Indians let off this
nuclear device at Admiral Jeremiah does
a study for the CIA what do you think
Admiral Jeremiah concludes we need
better human what is the DCI do he sets
up a whole system to improve human how
come it didn't start stopped 911 because
it is extremely hard and be wary of
so-called experts who come to you and
say well if we just had better human
they don't know what they're talking
about yes of course it would be nice but
I defy you looking through the history
of intelligence to show
any country with one exception which has
developed a strong group of penetration
agents the one exception was the Soviet
Union but it was a very narrow period
yes they found mercenaries into the 80s
and 90s we know those cases but in terms
of people in the core political
decision-making apparatus of their enemy
and it was because of the depression a
very odd series of events that created
old generation of people who were
somewhat confused about loyalty and they
and they found their way many of them as
we know through venona into the US
government but that stopped with the
coming of the Cold War and wasn't
replicated because we have the Soviet
stuff that we really need now so it's
very unusual so it's not let's not be
quick about that that the thing that has
to be kept in mind is that a lot of what
we need to know about countries you can
learn in open sources and by learning
their language and learning their
culture it I'm I'm no Iraqi specialist
by any stretch of the imagination but it
seemed to me I was just finishing a book
about Khrushchev that a Stalin is leader
and he and Saddam Hussein it modeled
himself after Stalin a stylist leader
would never admit weakness that that
because he had no particular legitimacy
I mean his position in the Iraqi
government was not very secure let alone
in the Middle East that the last thing
you would expect a Stalin is to do would
be to announce in front of the cameras I
have no weapons of mass destruction and
that his government would have all kinds
of reasons not to admit weakness the
Soviet Union never admitted weakness in
fact they did the opposite the used to
pretend they had weapons of mass
destruction they didn't have I suspect
that's what North Korea is doing that's
the way week countries always deal with
the United States they exaggerate their
power why it is and I don't have any
clearances why it is nobody until after
the WMD wasn't found then the CIA ran of
Team B and figured all this out why
didn't anybody do this during the period
you didn't need secret information to
know that he probably didn't have WMD it
has something to do with the value of
knowledge
understanding in government people are
busy in government there are pressures
on people to produce policies there are
a lot of explanations that that are much
easier and I think much truer than the
human problem and that's why it's often
a policy issue I'll take one more and
then I've got to go go ahead as a
historian you study patterns of the past
as you look into the future do you have
any ideas as to what we're gonna face oh
you see you jumped you see that that's
what historians don't do um but listen
listen I what I really want to come out
of this I have no particular wisdom on
this is I think that time and again the
problem was that that the American
people us we didn't understand the
nature of the threat my great fear is
that we have an attack on some mass
transit system in one of our major
cities and that we overreact that's my
fear today for example on my thoughts
are with the British the people who were
overreacting to what happened in London
were in CNN the CNN correspondence were
single maybe they'll maybe they open the
mass transit system too soon as Prime
Minister Blair reminded us all the
terrorists want us to destroy our own
way of life that's why they create
terror and the only way we can lose this
struggle is if we overreact that isn't
mean we have can't be vigilant we have
to be vigilant but we have to learn to
live with a certain level of awareness
and we also have to understand that we
always have acceptable risks in society
we drive to work every morning and there
is always the possibility we're going to
die now we've figured out we've sort of
worked work this through in our minds
and we go to work in life will you take
risks and the best way to stand up to
these people at the people and on time
but their counterterrorism specialists
or our military but for the rest of us
the way for us to join the fight is to
be tough vigilant determined and not let
these people get
their way that's the way you deal with
them I don't believe that our government
is preparing us properly I don't think
for example that the Pentagon announcing
today that they have stepped up security
measures because of for bad bombs in
London is a sign that we are showing the
kind of intestinal fortitude required to
be terrorists the largest and most
powerful military in the world should
not be stepping up security measures in
response to an attack thousands of miles
away when there's no credible evidence
that were any more insecure today than
we were yesterday that's not the way to
show that we're winning and that we're
the good guys so that's what I think we
should all learn and that's what we
should go in and and and and and and
tell our friends and that's the way we
beat these people they want us to be
terrified let's not let them so let
happen
Tim thank you for a terrific
presentation I'm sure most of us would
like you to come back next week at about
the same time pick up right here one
thing I would like to share with you we
just found out this week and we put out
a press release yesterday that our
exhibit which is the enemy within which
is a history of terror in America times
when Americans have known terror and as
you know the entrance is right here on
the mezzanine we'll go on tour and that
will it will close here right after
Labor Day and it will go on tour and the
first stop will be in oklahoma city at
the national museum of Morial so i can't
think of a more appropriate place for
that exhibit to start the tour so just
wanted you to be aware of that thank you
so much for coming this afternoon look
forward to seeing you again
Timothy Neftali worked as a contractor
for the 911 Commission he's co-author of
one hell of a gamble and US intelligence
and the Nazis his latest blind spot is
published by basic books on the web at
basic books calm